there are a few definitions of the term
citizenship
in this video we're going to talk about
two of those definitions
one is the legal definition
the status of having citizenship a
person has citizenship as a member of a
state which gives them rights
responsibilities and privileges
a citizen of the united states is
entitled to the protections granted in
the constitution and bill of rights like
freedom of speech
there are two paths to citizenship
people are either born citizens because
their parents were citizens or because
they were born on u.s soil or they can
become naturalized citizens we'll talk
more in other videos about the process
to become a citizen but for now just
know that naturalization is the legal
process by which a foreign citizen or
national can become a u.s citizen
the other definition of citizenship i
want to talk about here is not just the
legal status of having citizenship but
the practice of active citizenship
you practice good citizenship by being
an informed and active member of a
political community so what does it mean
to be a good citizen
there are a few aspects of good
citizenship
first a good citizen is empowered that
means that they exercise their rights
and believe that they can make a
difference by doing so they don't say
nah i'm not going to do anything it
wouldn't make a difference anyway
a good citizen is also community-minded
they feel a sense of responsibility for
their communities and they want to help
them be the best that they can be
they're also inclusive and by that i
mean that they want to do what's best
for everyone in their community not just
what would be most beneficial to
themselves
they include multiple viewpoints and
stand up for the rights of others
and lastly a good citizen is informed
they know how the government works
they're up to date on the problems that
the government is facing and the
decisions that it's making
good citizens are invaluable to
democracy because democracy works best
when citizens are knowledgeable and
active in political debate